not only did I win two student atomy  Awards I was nominated for an animated  short film award with luxo jr. and I  actually was lucky enough to win a Best  Animated Short Film Award with my film  tin toy tin toy  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh this is great Joey we did it we'd  like to thank the Academy for this great  honor because it's the first time this  award has gone to a computer animated  film we'd like to share this with the  computer graphics community the world  around but the computers didn't create  the films people did we'd like to thank  those people at Pixar firstly Evan Osby  who should be on stage with us tonight  great job Ralph Guggenheim great good  Deirdre Warren Susan Anderson just  everybody else Steve Madden Steve Jobs  thank you very much  [Music]